they will do any kind of thing to trap
the innocent civilians from kids and
women and men who are starving
specifically the
children do you want to speak with
confidence like these amazing
personalities every single one of these
amazing speakers have taken the same
program with brother Muhammad Arad
Muhammad Arad has helped develop allot
of us it's extremely beneficial to do
this course definitely recommend this
course to access the free lifechanging
training
now brothers and sisters and dear
friends just when you thought to
yourself that the Zionist satanic regime
could have not got any worser oh yes
they do we can't make this up guys I
mean if we suspend like millions or
billions of pounds like Hollywood does
with his fake stories of What Muslim
terrorists are Etc if we were suspend
this we could have never come up with
what they do originally and organically
themselves because they are evil within
themselves and they project on the
Palestinians by calling them Human
animals interesting so brothers and
sisters as you can see the whole entire
Globe has seen the mask drop of not only
the Western system but Israel as a whole
firstly I want to thank Israel thank you
very much Netanyahu the far right from
the IDF the MPS you name it from top to
bottom defense minister you name it
thank you very much we Muslims could
have not done it without you we could
have not shown the true side to you guys
without your help now here is a video of
them taking this evilness one step
further and letting the whole world see
now there are people starving to death
as you know and the ID of scum bastards
dirt bags are shooting at people who are
trying to get flow to feed their family
members now they've decided to be a bit
more creative in their evilness what
have they done here is a video Let's
watch for ourselves and you might find
it hard to believe oh not not with
design this nobody would anything goes
with them from the borders them sitting
with their children blocking food from
going in and people are starving to them
mocking kids who are dying this is just
another one we had to do this guys yeah
so let's watch for ourself inshah hello
everyone it's a really important video I
need you guys to share this to every
single person you know Israelis are
intentionally leaving cans that look
like uh meat cans so the starving kids
and the starving innocent people in
gazam from the starvation try to open it
uh to eat these are not food these are
bombs that once you open it it will
explode and kill whoever is around it
and next to it so please be careful they
have they are leaving it behind them in
the areas they're evacuating from such
as some areas in kanun some areas in the
north some areas in the South just be
careful and send this to everyone these
scans are explosive cans and they're
taking advantage of the hungry
specifically the hungry kids that
doesn't know how to read and doesn't
know Hebrew these are explosive cans
that could leave to your death and
everybody around it the Israeli soldiers
have no empathy for Humanity they will
do any kind of thing to trap the
innocent civilians from kids and women
and men who are starving specifically
the children who does not know how to
read so be careful and share this with
everybody you know specifically the
people in Gaza so interesting guys I'm
just just imagine the idea from the
Zionist net the Satanist the satanic
individuals coming together and like
okay how can we we already killing them
and we kill 30,000 innocent men women
and children and babies and how can we
cause more damage how can we take it to
the next level how can we be more
satanic oh I know we'll make little cans
so they look innocent for little kids
Etc we will not write a warning we'll
just write it on Hebrew so they don't
understand what they're doing we will
leave them behind when we have starved
them so they are desperate and then
we'll make it look like a can opener so
it looks like tuna or food and when they
open it they will blow up I mean do you
think this conversation did not happen I
tell you I have no shadow of a doubt
that the way it looks to how small it is
to the way it looks like can open up it
is all intentional guys we are dealing
with outright Satanist these people are
you look at them and you I think I think
Satan might be jealous he might be like
you know what Rob and I thought I was
theist they bloody young man he's like
they take to the next level yeah it's
like Satan was the teacher and they were
the students the students have gone past
the the teacher they've become triple
black black bills yeah okay so as you
can see guys and and alhamdulillah Allah
subhana tells in the Quran about how
they used to behave with M Alam Zionist
how they used to be how they used to be
with Mam and you can see very clearly
these individuals they are exactly how
Allah subhana wa ta'ala explains the way
they would challenge God and call Allah
stingy and you know what alhamd Allah
spoke the H and that's why Allah subh
says in the Quran that when he told the
children of Israel do not kill an
innocent soul I think there's a real
good reason why that was referred to the
children of Israel because you know what
because they are quoting scriptures and
calling quoting Massacre men women and
children you can never make this up the
far right tried their best to label us
as Muslims and those extremist
individuals in our groups like Isis yes
who were Muslims are evil Muslims yeah
misguided Muslims who the prophet P upon
warned against us and told us to finish
them off where you see them CU they are
the biggest enemies to Islam they tried
their best to equate that Islam teaches
the killing of men women children now
their funders who fund them the Zionist
yeah Tommy Robinson the bastards scum
dirt back little intellectual
midet is well who funds them guess what
they are quoting actual Biblical
scripture and carrying out those attacks
and justifying it and it's not just the
guys at the top it's from the bottom all
the way down and not only that the far
right scumbag dirt back supporters are
also saying yeah you know yeah the
Palestinians yeah killed them men women
children no problem alhamdulillah you
all have been exposed so next time share
is far and wide inshallah may Allah
bless you guys and alhamdulillah don't
worry like Allah says in the Quran they
are putting these bombs for the kids to
eat to explode they will eat from the
Tre the tree of zakum yes okay zakum
something that is fonny like the devil's
head and it will open up your Insight
inshah may Allah subh allow us to see in
Jenna we go to Jen and see in Hellfire
how you guys eat that tree inshah that
fruit inshah that fruit that's going to
destroy your intestines inshallah you
scum dirt bags doing this to innocent
children yeah may Allah subhana wa tala
and I would not wish that upon your kids
ever till next
time